deux autres ont tous et je retiens
d'abord c'était le nôtre coiffeur pour
le café aux terres sainville car c'est
coiffé tous les artistes
et puis c'est tout j'attends un parloir
un chanteur de charme
le blue air c'était sa musique préférée
il connaissait tous les classiques de la
musique cubaine de l'artiste au bureau
et je me rappelle une voix qui valent
quoi il se tait une chanson que que nous
avions sur 47 tours laurie-anne lma luna
et ça et le type soit être être quelques
tribus l'espagnol et puis il a repris du
pâtis guyane il achète du de goldman
michel sardou les mariés et il faisait à
l'époque 15 16 ans avec marseille au
mieux de vous dis cela avec jeanne le
guillou avec denis noté avec 16,8 mio il
faisait beaucoup de séries nabe est
beaucoup beaucoup d'anniversaires c'est
de faire à cette époque là la bonne
solide de dire cette ville et puis c'est
vrai depuis quelques temps il était
fatigué peu diabétiques que relâchés
s'ils ont mal depuis quelques cinq ou
six mois il a avec un petit peu la
musique en tous les cas je retiens de
lui cet homme qui a charmé beaucoup de
gens avec sa voix est aujourd'hui donc
qu'il est parti vers le lointain pays ou
de la terre mais restera toujours le
géant martinique et de papier pour
l'éternité